hey everyone it's Mike here and welcome
back to my channel you know I'm so glad
you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about the
importance of order flow Delta now
before we jump in if you enjoy learning
from these videos don't forget to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell so you never miss a new upload and
if you find today's video helpful be
sure to hit the like button for me and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway you know I love hearing your
feedback I go through the comments and
sometimes I make videos based off those
comments you know your support really
does go a long way in helping me create
more content just like this so if you're
getting value from my channel and you
want to see more you know be sure to
subscribe and let's grow together now
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic all right let's get into
it so
you know today is uh Monday April April
August 21st and the S PS you know we
opened up then rallied up to new highs
and had about a 30 point sell-off and
you know really what I want to discuss
is you know sort of what were some of
the clues in the order flow
to you know give Traders some signs that
the market was about to sell off and
you know the cash opened here at uh 8 30
Chicago time you know you know I got a
comment from somebody says what's that
mean Cash open you know really what you
know Futures are open
um you know basically 23 hours a day
they close from you know during the week
they close from what a four o'clock
Central Time to five o'clock where they
reopen but when I refer to the cash
hours obviously that that's when the
underlying stock market is open in the
U.S
um so we opened up went up came back
that pulled back and then we rallied up
to new highs and then we proceeded to
sell off quite sharply and
you know there was a comment on on a
video basically saying that Delta is
useless and yeah honestly I really
disagree with that um you know for me
delta
is you know one of the building blocks
of order flow right you need to
understand Delta and how it's coming in
not just a bars Delta by itself right if
you're just trying to analyze a Bar's
Delta by itself well every bar has Delta
it's going to be positive or negative
more or less you know there is times
where it just comes in at exactly zero
but that's just more coincidence than
anything else and with Delta especially
in the e-mini smps you know I find that
you know I have a certain range as well
so if it's plus or minus 50 I sort of
treat that as a neutral zone in terms of
you know it could have easily been
positive
or negative based off of one more trade
you know if I'm looking at a time-based
charts it just closes right after 60
seconds right if I'm looking at a one
minute chart so when I sometimes if I
see like a Delta of
-3 I know that if there's just one more
trade you know it could have been
positive so I just kind of treat it as
neutral I don't say oh this minus 3 is
the negative Delta right you know you
got to put it in context of the market
and it's especially true in
understanding where that negative Delta
comes in or where that positive Delta
comes in so let's just go back to the
open here right we opened up started uh
you know we open up basically around the
93 area rallied all the way up to o5 so
about 10 12 point rally pulled back a
bit back down to you know basically
right around the opening price and then
shot up to new highs okay now at this
new high any time we're trading around a
high or the low of the day this is where
understanding Delta
really comes into the Forefront right
you want to understand what is happening
um in terms of the aggressive buying and
the aggressive selling in the market
right and Delta obviously is just a
recap for those that are new to order
flow is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar I mean people the next question
is going to be what's an aggressive
buyer what's an aggressive seller well
there's
four types of Traders basically you have
aggressive buyers aggressive sellers you
have passive buyers passive sellers
people that work in bid
or work and offer are the passive
Traders the aggressive Traders are the
ones that
buy from the passive seller and the
aggressive seller is the one that sells
to a passive buyer so when you see
negative Delta it's telling you that you
had more aggressive selling in the bar
than aggressive buying if you see
positive Delta and you had more
aggressive buying than aggressive
selling okay so within Delta you have
a bunch of different numbers you could
look at right so the main ones that I
concentrate on is obviously the final
Delta just the Delta for the bar the max
Delta the Min Delta okay but then that's
sort of what we'll be discussing today
now Max Delta tells you how strong Delta
was in a bar
the strongest it was Min Delta shows you
how strong negative
Delta was in a bar so
I see up at this High I got a Max Delta
up 623. I've got a Min Delta of minus
279 so I know at one point in this bar
there was some decent aggressive buying
it was positive Delta of 623
and also in this bar the aggressive
selling was minus 279. so why is this
important well again you know if I'm at
a high of the day in this case today I'm
at the eye of the day I'm looking at
this High I'm not only going to look at
the final Delta of minus 212 right I
mean we're at the high of the day you
have aggressive selling come in that's
your first clue that hey you know what
maybe this Market can sell off
and I take it a step further I look at
the max Delta and the Min Delta and I
see that in this bar at one point there
was some strong aggressive buying of
623 in the max Delta so early on in this
bar there was aggressive buying we're up
at this high and we still have the
aggressive buying right that's what you
expect to see at new highs right you
want to see aggressive buying so not
only did you have that aggressive buying
but it shifted from
strong aggressive buying to aggressive
selling right we closed at -212 in the
Delta so this Delta it was plus 623
early on in the bar then the aggressive
selling came in over the remainder of
the bar and took the Delta from positive
623 back down to zero to sort of neutral
in terms of the delta in the order flow
then continued on into negative
territory minus 279 and finally the bar
closed with minus 212 in the Delta okay
so that's you know that's a bearish sign
so we're at the new highs of the day and
you have bearish order flow coming in
okay but that's just one part of the
puzzle right it doesn't mean you're
automatically going to get short now
when you start adding in you know other
pieces of the order flow right we see a
stack selling a balance coming in here
the 126 against 15 92 against one 182
against 37.
okay yeah I also have a thin print in
here of one contract okay so now we have
you know the negative Delta at the high
we've got aggressive selling in sense of
a stack selling a balance and you got a
little bit of momentum coming in here to
the you know bearish momentum with the
thin volumes towards the bottom of the
bar 15 137.
then what happens
Market next Bar opens goes inside not
exactly the most bearish bar that you'd
want to see what you'd want to see is
the market start to
come off a bit right start trading lower
than this bar that we made the high in
okay but you know you still want to give
it
you know another minute or so right you
just want to abandon this right away
then the next bar comes in you've got
a red candle down
okay technically it's an engulfing bar
previous to this green candle here but
again not necessarily such a big
engulfing Notes One tick above the high
of the bar one thing below the low one
selling and balance in there okay
nothing to get excited about but the
Delta is minus two to seven okay
now
the max Delta was positive 143 the Min
Delta was minus 233 and the final Delta
is closing at minus two two seven so
it's closing this bar is closing right
near our Min Delta number
which again is is a sign of bearish
information
okay but again we had bearish order flow
here and it just went sideways still let
the market tell you what's happening
then finally this red bar down we start
we break away to the downside from the
high
a nice strong negative Delta minus 431
again it's closing near our Min Delta
number of minus 438 that's why this is
magenta just like the 227 was magenta
look at the max Delta it's 58. so
not a lot of it was aggressive buying
but you know when the aggressive buyers
were in control it was quite small it's
just 58. so what's happened since we've
hit the high well we're at negative
Delta minus 212 one bar with positive
Delta of 270
negative Delta minus 227
negative Delta minus 431 we're starting
to move away from the high right
aggressive sellers are starting to take
control of this Market okay maybe you're
still not convinced yet maybe you still
need more convincing okay get another
red candle down here right this time I
mean the high came in at eight and a
half now we're trading you know 03 now
you got two cellular balances again a
nice strong negative Delta minus 514 the
max Delta was only eight so when
aggressive buyers were
in control of this bar they only managed
to take control by eight contracts
Min Delta is minus 702 which is quite
strong and we'll close that minus 5 14.
so it's still a strong number by this
point
you should really be thinking that this
Market's going to move lower rather than
reverse and come back up now of course
obviously if we start putting in you
know positive Delta in the next bar yeah
you can expect the market to potentially
move back up
okay then finally more
red candle more red candle negative
Delta negative Delta negative Delta
single print stack selling a balance you
got a two in here so thin volumes coming
in but really the signs were coming in
here earlier one bar two bars three bars
three out of four very negative
that's your sign that potentially this
Market can sell off now I wasn't
expecting it to really drop about 30
points it got all the way down to
um
you know pretty quick down here to uh
you know 86 even down to 84. again this
yellow line is the opening price from
last night
but I was looking for a you know at
least a pretty quick you know 10 point
sell-off extended another 10 points but
this is you know the importance of Delta
right understanding Delta not just on a
bar basis oh it's got negative Delta
what does that mean you start putting it
together right you're at your high of
the day
negative Delta one positive the negative
negative negative negative negative you
know they're selling coming in here I
mean obviously Red Bar Red Bar you got
selling imbalances you got stacks on
imbalances as well you've got thin
prints in there
it's just you know signs there for you
in the order flow now people are going
to say well you know we're going into
the high on positive Delta shouldn't we
have gone higher well
yeah we did go higher right we made a
new high but it all shifted in this bar
the strong positive Delta of 623 ended
up at just minus 212 and again any time
you're at the highs of the day going
into the high you're expecting to see
positive Delta right this is nothing out
of the ordinary 339 393 252 291 700
that's what
trading into the highs looks like but
when you start coming off from highs
this is what it looks like it looks like
negative Delta you know a positive
negative negative it's just consistent
negative Delta
all right all the way down but you don't
need to have 10 bars of negative Delta
you don't need the market to move 10
points you know before you realize oh
this is the high you could pick up the
signs early in the Delta right that's
the
power of order flow is it's cluing you
in
to what's happening right now in the
market right order flow is the market
it's not a trading strategy by itself
where you're like oh okay just tell me
where to buy and sell right no you want
to do the analysis right and it's not
brain surgery type analysis right you
just say oh we're at the high of the day
I got negative Delta that let's see
what's going to happen okay I got a bar
with positive Delta it's just inside
right no Direction yet because it's just
inside of the bar on the high the next
bar
technically it's inside of the bar on
the high but it's kind of an engulfing
pattern but you're back down to negative
Delta again I'm still not convinced by
this third bar but once it starts
breaking here that's your go sign
to be looking to get short in here in
this bar around you know maybe 02 to O3
area for the market to sell off
so that wraps up uh you know today's
video on the importance of Delta right
so I hope you found these tips helpful
for your understanding of order flow
again you know I make these I'm not
trying to say this is the strategy you
have to trade because the market is
unique right you don't get carbon copy
setups exactly the same every time you
know but
it if you look at the charts long enough
you start to understand that what you're
seeing is the aggressive selling coming
into the market so let me know what
you'd like to discuss you know what
you'd like me to discuss
um next by leaving a comment below so if
you enjoyed this video you know be sure
to hit the like button and subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss you know
my next video so thanks again for
watching and being a part of this
community I do appreciate your support I
do appreciate you taking the time to
write me a comment like I said I've been
a little bit more proactive and trying
to get back to people on their comments
um so I'll see you guys in the next
video so keep at it guys bye bye